[Music]  I'm gonna give it up I'm gonna give  props to Viola for being of all these  characters who are supposed to be so  intimidating and you are all badasses I  think the toughest character in the film  is your parent  [Applause]  what you're doing you have no  superpowers but you really have the most  I you're the one I fear the most kick  some ass yeah you got some you got some  direction from David Ayer the director  that helped you get under Joel's skin is  that right Really Trying he gets right  in my ear in those scenes because he  really wanted me to control him it's so  he's just leaned into me during one  scene he said call him a [ __ ]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Applause]  my power going in and then he said okay  okay now call my [ __ ] I said you [ __ ]  [ __ ] any woman to play a man the wall  afford a  you